October 1947 fire rages through appear on
Manhattan's West Side despite the efforts of
firemen ashore and afloat the pier is a total loss
now to replace the wreckage on new concrete pier
Rises not in Manhattan but 35 miles up the Hudson
a lake right next to the river was pumped dry to
form the largest natural dry dock in the world and
here three huge concrete boxes have been erected
but how does appear 35 miles up the river replace
one in New York well it's not going to stay here
they're going to float these massive shells down
the river or so they say the lake is refunded
and sure enough all those thousands of
tons of reinforced concrete do float a
passageway is dredged through the narrow
embankment a channel is dug out to deep
water and the first of the boxes is
eased out into the river with cables
six powerful sea going tug standby to
take over once the pier section is out
where they can get at it this remarkable
engineering venture was undertaken jointly
by Merritt Chapman and Scott Corporation
and the Corvette a construction company
under contract to New York City's
Department of marine and aviation
it takes half a day to navigate each of the
very seaworthy bulkhead boxes down river and
work them into position where they'll be sunk
by pumping water into them later the concrete
boxes will be pumped out and their buoyancy
will support 90 percent of the weight of the
superstructure that will be erected on top of
them in addition the boxes will serve as very
useful basements where cargo can be stored and
trucks and automobiles can discharge their loads
a model shows that when completed the
pier that went for a boat ride will be
one of the strongest handiest
most modern piers ever built